on the mound tonight for scott's service
it is the veteran tyler anderson
it's his 27th start of the season mike
his ninth in a mariners uniform yeah six
and nine record a 4-2 era for the
mariners at 380 ari so he's pitched well
for the mariners
cut on and missed
anderson strikes out the first batter of
the ball game
swinging a miss
tyler anderson retires to side in order
a couple of strikeouts to go along with
it
nathan devaldi 10-8 357 earned run
average
crawford swings to the first one and
rolls it into right renfro giving chase
it'll be a base hit
on the first pitch of the night for neat
if it comes down to one game who are you
gonna throw out there you know that's a
debate you could have because both those
guys have been outstanding i think they
both have been and certainly you know
chris sale coming back from tommy john
that's a swing and a miss henniger down
on strikes
that would be my obvious pick
[Music]
swaying in a miss he puts him away
that was pretty filthy back-to-back case
by baldi
friday's a sale day i believe swing and
a foul tip to the mitt held by powecky
and he struck him out came back with
three consecutive k's
two for 14 on the trip
up the middle and a base hit
quick start for the sox in the second
inning off the lefty that's a great sign
for him just seeing the ball down going
to get it keeping a nice line drive
swing going right up the middle you know
what i'll be doing i know the routine
the one-two
swinging in a mix well he tied him up
third strikeout early for tyler anderson
[Applause]
skimmed out to jp crawford onto first
for out number three that lead off
single is stranded through an inning and
a half nothing nothing
yeah he's a legit number one pitcher i
mean he goes out there the the mentality
is to go right after hitters like 99 to
strike him out his fourth in the book
and a two no score
j.p crawford and he says okay here i
come and he strikes out the side there
and then has been looking very very
tough here early on for boston swinging
bun anderson fields it perfectly
and he gets verdugo one out
[Applause]
oh he tied him up and a knot that's a
ballpark pretzel
strikeout victim number four for tyler
anderson
the bullpen
ranked by fan graphs
as one of the best one or two in the
game
down goes raleigh on strikes number five
for native aldi two gone
he's gotta go out there and score some
runs for him let him breathe
nasty struck him out tight breaking ball
to fan crawford he has six strikeouts
tonight
they got him
ripping right through a fastball over
the heart of the plate five strikeouts
for tyler anderson
a couple red sox and bats have been
driving up the pitch count this is the
eighth pitch of this one
for martinez
swing and he ripped that one down into
the corner he sucked it long but he also
hit it foul
plenty of distance on it but fouled it
away 3-2
but another good swing on that shot it
toward the alley way back there and that
ball is out of here
home run jd martinez number 26
so he rips one foul
this one he straightens out
and the red sox are on the board one to
nothing
right back to jp crawford
and a routine out number three the red
sox strike first jd martinez's solo home
run one nothing boston
good situation first second nobody out
ty france the hitter
luke's
hernandez coming in can't make the play
hannigar's coming
[Applause]
right center field hernandez and renfro
it is the right deal to retro drops it
he drops it
everybody is safe
gift wrapped on a platter
mariners have him loaded
foul tipped into mind he struck him out
one man gone as he gets kelvin
outstanding job making a pitch right
there kerball down to the zone exactly
where he wanted to throw it starts up
ends up down below three and two bases
loaded one down in a tie game
out to center this is checked it is deep
back on the track hernandez the catch
it will give the mariners the lead
seeger scores on a fraley sac fly
and it's 2-1 mariners and the bottom of
the fourth really good at bat
on the top of the already long inning
this is the seventh pitch of this at bat
for bowers
in there strike three came back with a
hook
[Applause]
seattle gets two though two to one at
the end of four
a little bit different than counting
everybody in the group
[Music]
this is out to right field hanukkah
angling back and he makes the catch
runners stay put no you're right that's
a good point
there's out number one scott is coming
out and he makes the call
tyler anderson not pleased
as you can understand
but scott is going to his pen
strike free call
he dotted that outside corner a couple
of times with a two-seamer at 92 miles
an hour the one-two
line seeger snares it on to second for
the force and the mariners get out of
the time of the fifth thanks to casey
sandler
see what he gets
for hennigar
breaking ball swung on and missed he
puts him away for the second time on
strikes
scooped up by dalbeck and that will do
it
closer 95 pitches for nathan avaldi
tonight a fly to left and a grounded a
short
gonna knock that one to right field
that's well hit that's back there it is
gone home run bobby dalbeck has tied the
game at 2-2 outstanding job going with
that pitch well you gotta love that
right field power
and smith deals and that swung on and a
fly ball pretty well hit racing back
hanniger all the way to the wall can't
get it he goes stunning into the fence
xander's off to the races he is heading
into third base he dives in with a
triple that's what he needed right there
that's the second day in a row where he
hit two balls off the wall
three and two to shorebird and here it
comes
swing and a line drive into the alley
here comes xander bogarts in the score
rafael debra's right behind him and the
red sox are in front here comes another
run throw to the plate and gets away and
shaw scores
and all the way down to third is kyle
schwarber and then schwarber comes off
the bench and delivers this one's going
to be ripped into right field headed
back toward the wall annette is out of
here that's a home run
a two-run shot for alex verdugo the red
sox open it up
seven to two
he's gonna slap that one down for a base
hit
that'll bring in another run xander
bogarts will score
debors to third
second rbi tonight for jd to make it
eight to two
ball out to verdugo and left field
granny's at third he tags and comes home
two outs now a sac fly for crawford 8-3
ball game
gave off that lead off base hit to jp
crawford on the first pitch of the game
and then really settled in this is
dropping into no man's land and it does
just that
play at the plate and safe terrence
scores mariners attack on another run
he struck him out 96 miles an hour and
that's the ball game the red sox beats
seattle
eight to four the final score
you